après Nike et decathlon c'est au tour du
groupe Sephora France de faire la
promotion du hit jab le 11 septembre la
célèbre marque de cosmétique a publié
une vidéo avec l'équipe desjabus ce
collectif créé en 2020 a pour objectif
de défendre le port du voile pour les
joueuses de football lors des matchs
dans la vidéo la marque va même jusqu'à
parler d'un véritable combat pour ses
jeunes filles je me sens à l'aise avec
ce groupe parce que je retrouve des
filles qui ont le même combat que moi
très vite la vidéo a été reprise sur X
ancien Twitter via le hashtag boycott
Sephora certains internautes accusent la
marque d'opportunisme ou de banaliser le
voile islamique systématiquement les
marques qui banalisent le voile
islamique en s'en servant comme un
instrument de promotion des hits jabus
comme modèle pour vendre ses produits de
beauté une stratégie risquée
l'anthropologue est spécialiste de
l'islamisme Florence berjo black l'air
s'inquiète elle d'une dérive islamiste
une firme multinationale reprend le
discours très riste de promotion des
droits des hitabus sans changer un mot
ce n'est plus de la certification c'est
de l'accréditation ici Sephora a crédite
l'islamisme en juin dernier plusieurs
associations dont les hits jab us
avaient contesté la décision de la
Fédération française de football qui
souhaitait interdire le port du voile
dans les compétitions de football
décision pourtant validée par le Conseil
d'État afin de garantir le bon
déroulement des matchs et prévenir tout
affrontement ou confrontation
[Musique]